people want to be happy and enjoy life
and sometimes on the left it's really
hard to do that right so if I
look on the right and I see Andrew Tate
like what's Andrew Tate telling me he's
telling me buy a sword be the master of
your own destiny go get you know work
get Bugattis get get do all this
stuff it's like okay well if I go to the
left what are they telling me it's like
well you need to feel bad because you're
white and you're systemically oppressing
everybody and capitalism is evil and
you're privileged and everything you do
is just because of your mom and dad it's
like okay well me right I feel like
the left comes down on you so hard and
it makes you feel like for
everything in society you know like oh
those shoes those were made by in a
slave shop or oh that food that you
bought the person is a victim of
capitalism and they probably don't have
a pension it's like okay I feel like my
important role is to show that like hey
I'm here I've got a lot of really
Progressive beliefs but I'm a happy
person I live a fun life like I make
money I don't think that any of this is
evil you can be a left-leaning person
and be aware of all these kind of social
issues that affect us without being
miserable all the time and
feeling like you're you know an evil
person